[Musique]
tout doux ultra-doux ultra comme frank
kerr ultra luxe ultra 3 ultra clean
caire velours ultraplat ch
les fabricants de papier gêné qu'on
travaille et ultra forts pour nommer les
produits qu'ils mettent sur le marché et
il y a les rouleaux double ou triple
avec des prétentions écologiques facile
de se perdre quand vient le temps de
choisir
[Musique]
mais y at il de si grande différence de
qualité une équipe de polytechnique
montréal a testé pour nous plus de
trente rouleaux de 15 marques
différentes
on approchait la version testée selon
les paramètres de l'utilisateur
on a pensé d'abord bon est ce que c'est
quelque chose qui va absorber l'eau
est-ce quelque chose qui vont résister à
la tension
est ce que ça vous résister à une
perforation
je dirais que sur l'ensemble de nos
rouleau in france n'était pas majeur
d'un point de vue mécanique c'est pas un
peu à papier particulièrement fort c'est
un papier qui est destiné à se dégrader
rapidement par la suite m
les quatre les plus performants sont le
choix du président max douceur quand on
l ultra comme franquin cachemire ultra
luxe et cachemire ultra 3
même si tous les produits sont reconnus
comme étant sûrs pour les systèmes
septiques le temps de dégradation de
certaines marques laisse pantois à
certains qu'on parlait de 5 10 15 ou 20
secondes mais dans certains tests fallu
interrompre après dix minutes puisqu'il
y avait toujours aucune dégradation
c'est le cas du charmant ultra strong et
de notre ici à cannes sauf fait à partir
de bambou ça ça nous dit quoi sur
qu'est-ce que ça fait un type de papier
comme ça ça veut dire qu'il va maintenir
son intégrité dans la tuyauterie dans la
plomberie donc ils vont rester intact et
peut éventuellement mener à des blocages
ma grande surprise c'était vraiment de
voir que systématiquement d'autres qu'on
avait une fibre recyclée ça se dégrade
et billets sont certainement mieux d'un
point d'eau
pour fabriquer du papier hygiénique soi
que l'on utilise des résidus de la coupe
de bois ou des fibres recyclées
provenant de papiers et cartons post
consommation c'est sûr que d'optimiser
les résidus de bois pour en faire du
papier toilette ça peut paraître louable
on peut se questionner sur la logique de
vouloir encore exploité des fibres
issues de l'industrie forestière pour
faire un produit en fait qui vraiment à
usage unique l'on peut pas avoir plus
usage unique quel papier toilette on
s'entend
si on veut s'assurer d'utiliser un
produit qui répond à des normes
responsable les deux certifications
importantes sont écologo et fsc
est reconnue dans le monde comme étant
un des organismes de certification les
plus crédibles en matière de foresterie
est la norme d'écolo beau c'est quand
même une norme à travers laquelle on va
chercher à atteindre le maximum de
performance dans l'industrie pour
différents critères que ce soit la
consommation d'eau la consommation de
produits chimiques les émissions de gaz
à effet de serre donc normalement
écologo c'est quand même une norme assez
robuste à laquelle consommateurs puisque
dans notre analyse nous avions aussi
deux produits à base de fibres de bambou
c'est vrai qu'il va pousser jusqu'à 20
fois plus vite là que les arbres dans la
forêt boréale par contre et vient de
très loin et c'est la chaîne
d'approvisionnement qui est difficile à
analyser dans ce colloque au delà de
l'approvisionnement local je pense qu'un
consommateur devrait opter en premier
lieu pour un papier recyclé si possible
avec la plus forte teneur en fibres
récupérées post consommation c'est là
qu'on va avoir le gain environnemental
le plus important
bienvenue chez vous au royaume du
textile nous avons demandé à des
finissantes et une enseignante du centre
des textiles contemporains de montréal
de nous donner leur avis sur la douceur
des papiers d'abord les quatre papiers
n'ont fait de fibres recyclées ayant les
meilleures notes à la suite des tests de
polytechnique pratiquer votre petite
peluche à l'effigié
[Musique]
ans
je dirais plus ou moins long et moins
bon que le premier
[Musique]
le gagnant le colonel ultra comme frank
kerr dégâts structurels
il est moins le lead où il y à 12 mois
c'est celui-là que j'achèterai
maintenant les cinq produits faits de
matières recyclées qui de l'avis même
des fabricants sont moins doux parce que
leurs fibres sont plus courtes que
existants mais moi nous parce que c'est
possible soit comme recyclé il ya des
petites pose-t-il
les trois premiers sont des marques
maisons soit sélection compliments et le
choix du président il semble être
fabriquées par la même usine les motifs
en beauce et étant identique à cette
élection qui se ressemblent plus que la
première
dans la première on avait plus de
différentes dit seles en plus si le
verdict maintenant
moi je serrais côté douceur ça serait le
b2b 2006 le b2
selon nos expertes le plus doux du
recyclé et compliments pensons vert
du côté des prix il vaut mieux se fier
aux petits caractères au prix courant on
remarque qu'il n'y aurait pas davantage
à acheter en grosse quantité et que le
rouleau soit double ou triple n'y change
rien l'important est de calculer le prix
de revient par feuille nous constatons
alors que la plupart des papiers fait de
fibres recyclées sont plus économiques
pour ce qui est des deux gagnants au
test de douceur le quota neige il devra
comme fred qu'elle se détaille à 500
pour 10 feuilles alors que le compliment
pensons vert et presque la moitié moins
cher à 3,5 pour la même quantité sim à
l'envers quoi devrait jamais j'y
répondrai initialement vers le capitole
à gérer vers le bidet si je veux laver
ma vaisselle après avoir marché du
spaghetti est ce que je vais prendre un
essuie-tout où je vais rester avec de
l'eau c'est un peu la même idée en
utilisant le vide et on utilise un jet
d'eau qui nous permet ensuite de réduire
notre consommation de papier toile à la
même facture d'un rouleau de papier
toilette prendrait jusqu'à 140 litres
d'eau alors que quand on va utiliser le
bidet c'est environ 600 militent donc on
va utiliser à chaque nettoyage donc
c'est très compétitif
considérant qu'en moyenne chaque
canadien consomme environ 100 dollars de
papier par an l'achat d'un bide et
adapté à la toile est peut-être une
solution économique et certainement
écologique